what are the signs that the relationship
isn't worth fighting for I'll tell you
the biggest sign and I learned this when
I watched this man who's a divorce
attorney talks about his cases and what
he thinks about marriage what he thinks
has the chance of working out versus
like what didn't work out and he asked
the woman cuz he was representing her
and said what was the moment that you
realized that the relationship was done
she said that he every morning would
always make sure that her granola was
refilled not even have to ask and just
always refill it for her right he'd
write these little Post-its too for her
when he was leaving even after all these
fighting he'd still do it the day she
knew that the relationship was over was
when he stopped filling the granola
stopped doing the letters because he
stopped caring the moment you realize
the relationship isn't worth fighting
for is when you realize that that person
just doesn't care you're just tired you
give up it's the giving up part she
realized in that moment that he just
didn't have anything left in him to keep
the relationship going